what up guys welcome to the chest pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to like the
video on your way in and subscribe to
the channel a like is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams also we're trying to hit 2
million subscribers before the end of
the year also guys make sure you get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
you know you could be the ultimate alpha
male women will come up to you left
right and Center just saying you are so
amazing and awesome get yourself a
t-shirt today okay so today's topics
guys okay so guys about five months ago
there was a woman that I kicked off of
the pregame and what I cannot stand is
when people come onto my show with a
preconceived notion about me and already
have an agenda they're trying to push so
this woman um I ended up kicking her off
the show let me let me show you guys the
because traditionally the woman has
being the one who stays at home
Cooks but why but why are we punishing
the men for doing what they're supposed
to do like you want you got wait wait
you want a guy that protects and
provides right that's what we
traditionally want but when a guy do
does it he loses his kids no one said
that's what we should you should punish
them cuz like men and women are
different men go and build houses women
look after their kids women build houses
men can look after kids there are stay
home dads who do exactly the same job as
women when the women are out there
earning the bread like that's a minority
of Rel
does happen you you need to accept that
that does happen we know like duh but
it's like we don't have to we just said
let's not acknowledge every exception we
know there's every there was are
exceptions and you the first thing you
say here's the exception we know we know
I think what the lady is simply doing is
trying to bring up the facts and I agree
that we should actually be holding men
and women equally accountable because we
should be saying that there are men who
should take
responsibility let me finish let me
finish I was speaking
okay get out go go bye I told you no I
told you a millionth time I haven't done
anything wrong okay all right bye why
what why why do you want me to I'm
asking you to go thank you you don't
like the fact that I'm challenging your
viewpoints no I don't really people
challenge my viewpoints all the time I
don't I don't like that you're being
rude I'm not being
rude
okay
nice meet
you feminists P do you not like it when
people have opinions no she her asked
her to stop multiple times and she
didn't she there's a rule we were told
the rules before we came so yeah but she
did try and talk a few times and P
didn't let her talk she just told her
show all right all right because it's
not your show if you want to put on a
show and talk when you want to talk show
not that good I've never heard of it
it's only fans hand you don't know
live streams every Friday and Saturday
oh my God on
Sunday so this show was interesting and
I actually I got a bit of flak for this
because they were like why don't you
just let her talk and the problem you
get in is as a show host people go on
long tangents that go off topic and if
you don't get people to stick to the
point then you end up with an outof
control show and I'll even say as a HST
like this is probably the hardest thing
to balance is like controlling your
guests at this woman the whole show
she's accusing me of being a liar and
it's interesting because they don't go
on the show in good faith now what is
good faith it's assuming the best in
people and you get people that already
don't like you they already have an
agenda they're trying to go viral
they're really just coming on the show
to go viral and it's interesting because
I saw another video of this woman go
viral this week I got a lot of flak for
it they said Pearl just let your guests
do whatever you want and it was so funny
because the one
chick she was like she was like oh I put
on a show too I'm like [__] you're on
only
fans get out of here okay but anyways
let's let's pull up the next one um as
you guys if you guys remember last week
I had a discussion uh with our sister
what was your name sister zarena matcha
sister zarena Matra so we had a
discussion and we started off with a
green which was about feminism and you
know all the stuff that they say so we
was in agreement with that we had a
difference of opinion certain matters
and it was look discussions happen
discussions are not where we speak to
people that we agree with I'll be honest
I have a podcast which is called uh
bitter truth and I invite people that I
disagree with so it's totally
understandable that we had some
disagreements however you did come back
today and I think you wanted to maybe
please tell us I I mean I don't I don't
want to speak for you please tell us
what happened well you see in the
comments of the video a lot of people
said that I was trash and loose and run
through and you're absolutely right I am
run through and that is exactly why I
believe that Islam is the solution
because you see for horish Western women
like myself we certainly need Islam to
teach us a good
lesson okay okay sister what I would say
is this following I would say firstly
ignore the comments uh anybody that's
called you a whatever I don't want to
repeat after but it was thanks to you
you a thumbnail of me like that didn't
you Ally okay so all right so I think I
think okay so let's let's let's come to
Let's I unless people that didn't know
anything about me trash CH about me in
the [__] comments do you ever
something think I that made me feel
listen to me I am not a piece of [__]
where the women are not trash okay there
is nothing wrong with the way I was
dressed you set me up I didn't know what
a [__] debate you me of [__] now
listen this is who I am this is who I am
you have 1 million subscribers Ali you
could have used it to help me you could
have used it to help somebody smaller
than you what a [__] a big con decorator
because okay are sure people much
smaller than them I am not trash I an
author and a musician and a YouTuber
okay
what no that was wrong that thumbnail
was wrong okay you don't treat people
like that you don't treat people like
that oh I was being sarcastic for God's
sake I want you I don't want you to look
at me for God's sake okay you tell your
audience that the IQ a [__] bubblebee
I'm sorry I said that I would rather
hang myself than become a muslim okay it
was rude I did not mean that but For
Heaven's Sake you did not need to set me
up like that I did not want to debate
you you should not have done that to me
that is not how we treat people are you
finish this though no I'm a person I did
not deserve that I to sit there my
brother had to see those comments you
know what your [__] followers said to
me that was rude
you said men use women for sex you use
the woman for likes on
YouTube 100,000 views I will get my
right arm to have 100,000 views on the
YouTube channel Al
want 100,000 views make a me like a
piece of [__] so you can have a good
laugh about it did you make a lot of
money out of that video did you have a
nice week eh I got 300 [__]
subscribers I thought we were going to
have an intelligent discussion about
feminism I thought we going to been a
very Gable discussion a Muslim and
Muslim talking about feminism but no you
made me look like a piece of [__] it was
horrible imagine if my dad saw that
there was nothing wrong with the way I
dressed Western women are not trash okay
just because you don't want to wear
buers and not make us trash for I am not
a be of [__] he set me up you knew
exactly what you did you set me up
finish finish it was rude your you not
have done that to me you should not have
done that to me okay sister finish your
claim then I can talk just tell me
you're making
accusations I don't want to say anything
else to you you take this take thank you
thank you very much I don't know what
got do me okay so let's just yeah let's
just bring some
clarification what the what was the
thumbnail that said they have the
picture of the
thumbnail why she lost it I mean if
anything he's helping her dress more
modestly with the the thing okay so
there was a couple things that she said
that were interesting she said she would
cut her right arm off for 100,000 views
this is a woman that is going around
trying to go viral and then gets mad at
the consequences guys I have gone viral
for many things all right many things in
my career and I am well aware that
comments will be positive and comments
will be negative you cannot control the
comment section sometimes the comment
section loves me sometimes the comment
section hates me it's part of life and
being on the internet so she also said
she would rather hang
herself um I I I didn't write down the
full quote but it was something along
the lines of yeah it was I would rather
hang myself than read the Quran she she
puts out disrespect and then wonders why
people are disrespectful towards her and
women like this go around they go
through life they just live in la la
land and they have no idea how they come
off to other people
this girl had been read the rules so
many times on my show she knew what she
was signing up for we tell them look it
sometimes as a host we have to interrupt
to control the flow of the conversation
it's nothing against you we read them
these rules before the show and I know
that when I go on other shows it's just
part of being a show host but she comes
in she tries to insinuate I'm a liar and
then wonders why I'm not overly patient
with her she goes around being
completely disrespectful to people and
then
wonders why they do not give her the
benefit of the doubt and what I really
wanted to point out is what we can learn
from this
situation guys I think that half of
women have a mental disorder I think
half of women today really if you push
them even if it's completely reasonable
if you disagree with them in the
slightest many have this reaction we
have many women that are going around
literally with mental disorders this is
not normal this is not healthy and I
think partially the media plays into it
I think a lot of times it's off Family
Dynamics I don't really know um it's
funny because the thumbnail says why she
lost it I mean the question is did you
lose it or did you not lose it and just
based off of this picture she seems
pretty pretty upset and then instead of
taking accountability for her action she
goes around and blames everybody else
it's the YouTuber's problem and the
funny thing is the way his mics are set
up you literally have to hook up your
mic so you know exactly what you're
doing you know what you're signing up
for but women want to sign up for this
stuff and then play the victim later